Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and dive into the layered materials
in Unreal. And we're going to break this up into three different parts. The first part
we're going to be looking at is the old school way to make layered materials using
material functions. So let's get started. So let's go ahead and jump to Unreal. As
you can see, we have three different samples in the Unreal file. We have one, the old
school way, and this is using material functions, allowing us to layer the materials
appropriately. Another one is a layered material in that we're using some blend
layered material functions in here to be able to make it so that we can have a
little bit more control. And the interface and building it is a bit
simpler. And finally, over here, we'll have the motion design, which allows us
to be able to build and create our materials in a more simplistic way. And
you can see the interface for it. This is the newer kid on the block, and
we're going to save the best for last. So let's go and dive right in and take a look
at this here. Simple, this year old simple material layering, and how this
works. So what we want to do first, let's go to our content browser, we go
to our class folder, we have an in class old way, and then in class NPC
and a few other things. What we want to do is go into our old way. And we're
going to create a brand new folder. I just have these samples in here for you
to play with and experiment with. But we'll just make a new one for
here. We'll call this a new sample. And we'll call it in class. And if
you want, you can truncate some of that if you need to. Sometimes
windows can be tricky on these. So we'll just keep these all
sandwiched together. There we go. And I'm going to double click on
this. And we're going to go ahead and make a brand new material
function, as well as a brand new parent material. So I'm going to
right click here and we'll do the parent material first. I'll
do material. We'll call this material blend. We'll do m
underscore in class, underscore mat, blend, or say
layered, we'll just put la, er. There we go. Can't spell
that in. Now again, you can make them smaller if you want
to. This should be okay, not a problem. If you go beyond the
number of characters I have, things can get a little bit
messy. But this is going to help you organize if you have the
samples open at the same time. Next, we want to go and make a
material function. So let's go and make that material
function. So let's go to materials here. underneath
materials, you'll see there is a material function. If we
go to advance, you'll see material function there. Let's
click on this. We'll call this m f underscore new wood.
And then we'll do another one. Go to materials again. And
then go to advance going to material function. We'll call
this m f underscore new moss. There we go. There we go.
Awesome. So what we want to do is let's build out the
material functions first, because we need to plug them
in into the later parent material, which will allow us
to house all the blending and to be able to control a few
things. So let's go ahead and look at moss first. So
let's go and pop this up. Now anytime you get lost, feel
free to look at the versions that I have set up. You can
simply just click on this one because this is the primary
one we're working with. And you can see we have a
material bark moss sample O2. And you can crack that
open. And when you crack it open, you'll be able to see
how things land. And you can double click on any of the
material functions to see what I've built. I have notes
in there too, that can help you kind of navigate a
bit. So let's go ahead and build out this first one
here, which is going to be our moss. One of the first
things, let's go full screen here. Let's go and turn off
the preview. So I'm gonna right click this. I'm going to
say hey, let's stop previewing. Now we get that
error to go away. And let's go and build this out. Now
this one may seem a bit complicated, but it is not.
Let's click on the grid, grid here. And first thing
we're going to do is make sure that we're going to
expose the library. You can forget this if you're not
careful. So we'll do this ahead of time. Expose the
library, you'll find out in the details. Next we want
to do is do create a node called make material
attributes. It's going to make material. There we go.
attributes. This will allow us to actually add and
combine and do whatever you want, given us the full
power and range of a material to craft it from the
ground up. Now we don't have any outputs yet. If we
connected this, there's still a few things needed, but
feel free to connect it if you want to ahead of time.
Alright, so once we have that set in, let's go and bring
in our textures that we need. One of them is we're
going to need that moss texture. So let's go and
grab that real quick. And we can simply type on
content and type in moss. And we can see that we
have our moss albedo. Now to keep things pretty
grounded and making sense. We're going to grab the
moss, normal, the moss albedo, we'll grab the
the moss here. Now we have a stronger moss and a
kind of a lighter moss, normal, I'm going to grab
the stronger one. And this particular case, and I'm
going to grab the rough, I'm going to pull these
three in here, we're going to keep it pretty simple
in that regard. Now that we have this in place,
let's go and build this out and get it to where we
want. So let's go move the normal down here, we're
going to move the albedo up here, just shuffle
things a little bit. What we need for the albedo is a
little bit of support. So we're going to use a
node called fuzzy shading. It's been around in
Unreal for quite some time. And the fuzzing shading
is going to give us a nice little drop off on
the edges here for this particular texture. Now, if
we want to, we can expose this, but we're not
going to worry about that because this isn't
really an instance in a more of an instant
scenario, we can make it so that we promote the
parameter. In this case, we just needed to be able
to hold that spot, or that slot, I should say
a slot, it's like slot, but it's more violent, I
don't know what that means. So let's go and pull
this over into a power node. So let's create a
power node. There we go. And this power node
simply kind of acts like a multiply, in this case,
and we're going to go ahead and for the little
cost here that we want to get a little bit of
strength going on, we can promote that to
variable or parameter, I should say. And we can
keep that at zero if we want to. Now that we
have this in place, we're going to put punch
this right into the base color. I'm going to
move this section of these back a little bit
here. Next, we want to get the normal map in
place. So let's go and grab that normal maps
down here. And we're going to get this pretty
simple, we're going to punch the normal map
inside of our fuzzy shading right there. And
then we're going to expose some of these
parameters here, core darkness, power and edge
brightness. And this is really up to you what
you want to make for these. So since it's not
really a material instance, we can simply just
make a constant so I can just keep my finger
on the one key. And we'll make this first one
to 0.5. That works. And we're going to punch
that 0.5 right into our core darkness. For our
exponential here, we're going to change this a
bit, we'll make this one a 0.3. I think that
works. It's up to you as you check out these
values and create them how bright or how dark
you want it to be. I'm putting it into that
result for now we're not finished them. So once
we have that in place, we're going to go in
here and in our core darkness, we have it set
up for 0.5. And we're going to make we need
punch in our constants into here. So we're going
to make some generic constants here, we'll do
keep my finger on the one key left click, and
then do it again. And I'll put the zero into
power, and zero into edge brightness. And it's
up to us if you want to adjust these in here,
or later somehow get them to be able to expose
them generically if you want to, but we're
going to keep them like this for now. And
that's should be just fine. Next, we're gonna
go ahead and get the multiply going. So we'll
get hit my finger on the M key left click. And
we're going to punch this right into the
multiply. I'm going to put this right into the
base color, because we want to be able to
magnify that green color if we needed to. So
we're going to go ahead and create a four
constant here. In this four constants going to
allow us to be able to, or actually we can do
a three vector. So let's do a three vector
instead. This allows us to be able to change
that color information, give a finger three key
left click. And let's make this kind of a
nice green color. This can be as green as you
want it to be. Okay, and move this into the
channel. Now you'll notice we don't have a
lot showing up yet. But that's okay. Because
we need to actually go in here and do a
preview. So we can go in here and say, hey,
let's preview this. And if you do a preview,
you'll be able to see what you're getting.
Now you'll notice it's super vibrant, right? So
we could probably make this a little bit
darker. So we can go in here and get a
little bit darker with the green. There we go
and hit OK. Like give us maybe a little bit
more believable green. Again, you can play
with this if you need to. So next, let's go
ahead and add a few more things. Let's grab
that normal information and actually punch it
into the normal. There we go. And we can
determine how strong that's going to be. Now
I'm just using a generic like moss and
normal in here. It can be this detailed or
you can change the UVs if you want to, but it's
up to you. We're gonna leave that for now. And
then finally, we want to go in here and
control the roughness. We can keep it pretty
simple. We can hit the M key, we can punch in
that roughness in the A channel. In my sample,
you'll see that it's set to the B channel. In
this case, we'll just do the A channel because
that works a little bit better. And then we're
going to go ahead and create a multiply or a
constant that we can use to punch in here. And
we'll set the constant to like, I don't know,
0.9. And then we'll punch that right into the
B channel and put this right into the roughness.
There we go. Oh, that looks really great. That
should do just fine for what we want. And
again, this is up to you how you want to
adjust it, how you want to control the details.
That's pretty much up to you. From there, we're
going to hit apply. And then now we have our
moss set up. In the next video, we're going
to make the wood texture material that we're
going to a material function that we're going to
add. And then we're going to start getting
this all set up to be blended. Thanks again.